in our series unifying america we are
recognizing efforts to right injustices
and bring communities together
pricey manhattan beach california is now
grappling with a very complicated racial
history
nearly 100 years ago a black family
owned a prosperous resort there
catering to people of color until the
city used a legal tactic to seize their
land and then just
dry them out as carter evan shows us a
plan is being unveiled today
that could return the land to the
family's descendants
manhattan beach is a favorite for
seeking a spot on the sand or a stroll
on the strand where homes can sell for
upwards of 20 million
but it looked a lot more like this in
1912 when willa and charles bruce bought
an ocean view lot
for around twelve hundred dollars they
were among the city's first
black landowners they had the bath house
here in the dining hall
dwayne shepard is the family historian
he says the l.a county lifeguard
headquarters now stands where willa
built
bruce's lodge it became a popular
destination for the black community when
segregation kept them off most beaches
so people weren't supposed to cross this
to go to the beach they had to walk a
half mile
in either direction before they could
get into the water barricades were built
tires were slashed and one real estate
agent even admitted he was trying to end
the quote
negro invasion there was a chapter of
the ku klux klan they started harassing
my family around
1920 they burned across they threw
burning mattresses under the porch of
one of the buildings
here were some black lives and they
didn't matter
a hundred years ago but i think they
matter now
the resort was right here it was right
here l.a county supervisor janice hahn
first learned what the bruce has endured
when the black lives matter movement
sparked conversations about
racism and income inequities i never
knew that we had a story right here in
manhattan beach
of an african-american family that
literally had their property stolen
from them city leaders ultimately used
eminent domain to shut down the bruce's
thriving business and make way
for a park it's a legal maneuver city
and county leaders now confirm
was racially motivated these people were
terrorized
and kicked out of a community where they
were trying to live peacefully
it really was an injustice to their
whole family generations
generations who surely would have been
millionaires
today if that beachfront property had
remained in the family
over the last century the city has grown
and prospered
but it ruled out reparations to the
family for lost income
that would be considered an illegal gift
of public funds
manhattan beach mayor suzanne hadley
says the council did
authorize spending 350 thousand dollars
on art to commemorate the family
and this week voted to acknowledge and
condemn what happened
but chose not to offer an official
apology it's awful it's wrong
we're not that community now i wouldn't
live here if we were a racist community
and my friends and neighbors would not
live here as well
last month a group calling itself
concerned citizens of manhattan beach
even took out an
ad in a local paper claiming some are
trying to create a racist
problem where there is none do you think
manhattan beach is a racist community
so we are less than one percent
african-american
that defines racism to me for some 20
years melissa clinton raised her kids in
manhattan beach
back in 2015 at two in the morning
someone threw a burning tire at the
family's front door
they escaped unhurt but the trauma
remains what it reminded me is that
things
haven't changed that much that terror is
still real
people who look like me are terrorized
we aren't entitled to
the comfort of security her neighbors
rallied around her so the family stayed
but clinton wonders what the city would
look like today
if bruce's beach had not been shut down
this community might be teeming with
black folks
if we had not destroyed that family it
changed the trajectory not only of their
lives
and their offsprings but of this
community to help usher in
change supervisor han teamed up with
state legislators to propose
giving the property back to the bruce's
descendants
the county would then lease the land
back from the bruces
creating income for the family i think
it's a moment
for manhattan beach i think it's a
moment for la county
that we could maybe be a model for the
rest of the country
do you ever think about what willa and
charles would have thought all this well
they would have loved it
i'm sure they're proud of us right now
for fighting to get that back
we're all proud of you after hearing
that story there was carter evans
reporting i mean
i love melissa where she said you know
burning tire was was thrown through the
home that doesn't actually say welcome
to the neighborhood
but the other neighbors did rally and
the fact that they want to rectify it
and
make it better and correct it says a lot
about that commitment everybody can
agree that the burning tire is a problem
but more people need to agree that the
historical
wealth gap is a problem and that goes
back to property property is wealth
and it cushions your life for
generations and this is an example of
that